a Michigan couple quarantine with the  coronavirus had to wait nearly three  weeks to meet their newborn twins  Jennifer and Andrew loboc met their sons  for the very first time last Thursday  this is nice little Mitchell and Maxim  were born eight weeks early in the weeks  leading up to their births both Jennifer  and Andre experienced symptoms of the  virus the night Jennifer went into labor  a doctor called to say Andre tested  positive and could not go with her to  the hospital so Jennifer was forced to  drive a half hour to the hospital by  herself  yikes leaving her a husband behind it  was heartbreaking cuz I didn't know if I  was like I was fearful for his life I  didn't know if I was gonna see him again  enjoy each moment that you have is you  don't know what the future will hold you  sure don't the couple and both babies  are doing okay so Anthony the circle of  life continues that's great